Iraqi special forces control every part
of Eastern Mosel now the streets are
coming alive as people realize the
threat of Islamic state has been pushed
away from here but this is still a city
at war in the battle for its streets
isn't over yet this is just the first
phase the commanding officer of the
Mosel assault assigned Sky News a
protection team to reach a recently
discovered Islamic state secret weapons
factory and it is a factory they were
building on an industrial scale the
warehouse is filled with rockets
designed for fighter jets Islamic state
have been modifying them for use on the
ground almost exactly a year ago we came
across video which was basically a
training manual that was due to be
distributed amongst Islamic state
operatives certainly around this region
but further afield as well and in it we
saw missiles just like this being worked
on and being changed this would appear
to be the type of a program and where it
ended up here in Iraq the pile of welded
steel rods of the launch stands this was
designed to be an arsenal of incredible
power but the Iraqis have discovered it
is far more sinister than previously
known the air stinks of chemicals were
told to touch nothing French Special
Forces say the site is contaminated with
poison but have yet to identify which
poison here though hidden beneath the
trees they were preparing enormous
missiles with chemicals and producing
weapons designed to cause mass
casualties so China 1000ft wonder
audience inaudible no authority from
another mother chameleon
dice Danny who use it this is their
weapons and we put chemical stuff how to
use it and luck as you saw when you
enter this place in refrigerated
shipping containers filled with coke
they found boxes of chemicals all kept
at near freezing temperatures again
they've been taken away for analysis
this site reveals a sophisticated
armaments wing of Islamic state run by a
team skilled enough to deal with deadly
substances aimed at bringing horror
nearby the Special Forces find this a
two-man light aircraft that they're
building from scratch they think it was
to be used for a suicide attack or to
drop bombs
it does seem bizarre but again it
underlines the sophisticated intent at
least of Islamic state the battle
continues on the southern edge of the
city mortars are fired in to Islamic
state positions a few hundred meters
away across the Tigris River the east
and west of Mosul are split by the river
the city's bridges have now been blown
[Music]
in the coming weeks the Iraqi military
will advance to the west and attempt to
push Islamic state out stung by present
Trump's description of this mission to
free the city as a disaster the
commanding officer points out that they
are on the ground and need America's
support to finish the job
American airpower is vital Fallujah for
example colleges need one month with the
support for coalition forces but without
coalition forces maybe in high state six
really that was the defense it was many
many more soldier right and that's
exactly the same in every battle of the
result okay so the result will be the
same but it could take a lot longer yes
it was many many many times and of
course the civilian population suffers
thing how long the mission to clear
Mosul will take or even when the Western
operation is due to start simply aren't
known while the East enjoys its new
freedom from Islamic state the western
side of the city is preparing for a
fierce battle peace is still a distant
hope through Ramsay Sky News Mosul